valuetainment giving values contagious
this world are entrepreneurs we gain no
value to haters how they run homie look
what i become
the one
oh my god okay so are we live episode
number one 180 um today's guest a
special one
uh he may look like
uh a hispanic colin kaepernick but it's
not coming out okay then don't don't you
know don't get too excited
it is uh actually somebody way more
interesting to me
a former uh covert ci operative okay who
uh went to school at south florida state
then went to the united states air force
academy he's now a fortune 10 corporate
advisor and at the same time
when he was in for seven years he and
his wife his wife was also a
cia agent they had a kid and they had to
make a decision on what to do i think in
2014
uh they decided to get out and try the
civilian life which is a very strange
adjustment if you've been
living in that life to go to this life
we'll find out about it today but with
that being said andrew dostomante but
we're going to call you andy on the
podcast if that's okay with you yeah
great good to have you on man thanks man
i'm happy to be here what a story you
got well i i appreciate it so it's my
story so like all of us we think our
story is the least interesting story
that's a good point you always want to
know other people yeah yeah yeah so for
people that don't know maybe share with
the the audience on
and by the way if you're listening to
this and you want to know kind of what
things we're going to cover here's some
things we're going to cover obviously
we're going to cover the background i
want to know some things about
the credibility of the different
agencies for me
uh i i have a hard time believing that
agents can
um you know
separate their emotional opinions
versus actually seeing stuff like hey
this data says bad things about the guys
support you i don't want to see that
versus this data says good things about
the guys but yeah this is what we found
out on the intelligence i have a hard
time in the last few years i think a lot
of people would probably agree that uh
the trust and i know you left in 14 so
in 14 it still wasn't that bad but since
16 it's been very very
taxing on any of the agencies cia fbi
nsa you name any one of them they lost a
lot of
credibility so how do you you know
differentiate between emotional side
what your own opinions are versus the
data you're getting we want to talk
about some of the stuff with the laptop
you know an article came out from new
york post saying 79 percent
say truthful coverage of hunter biden's
laptop would have changed the 2020
election which means trumps would have
been trump would have been president
today
zuck's uh guest appearance on the rogan
podcast a lot of stuff was said there
that uh
got people thinking he's talking to the
fbi and you know how
decisions they made with the laptop
we'll talk about mar-a-lago since it
just happened a lot of talk about civil
war and some of the media platforms just
recently you know cnn's talking about
were trying to be less of a democratic
mouthpiece they just let go of stelter
they just let go of uh not just let go
there cuomo cuomo was a a year ago and
lemon's on possibly lemon you know if
they lose lemon they may go out of
business but that's the challenge
and a few other things so we'll cover
those things here but for the audience
that doesn't know your background if you
don't mind sharing briefly how you went
about becoming a cia agent yeah
absolutely and i mean that's a super
exciting lineup that you just laid out
there patrick so i'm going to try and
keep my piece as tight as possible
so i was at air force academy
for college i was a brown kid in
pennsylvania if you're brown and in
pennsylvania i get you and all you want
to do is get the hell out of
pennsylvania
so that's where i started i was looking
at any and all options just desperate to
to do something that got me out of rural
pennsylvania what city were you on i was
in harrisburg okay which is the actual
capital of pennsylvania nobody knows
that everyone thinks of pittsburgh
philly
we all remember fifth grade when we got
that one wrong yeah right in our fifth
grade harrisburg
sorry 49 out of 50 buddy
so uh so i found out that there are
these military schools
that give you free scholarships and
that's what took me to the air force
academy so i just kind of went all all
all roads to rome try and get to a free
military education
i was successful i was the first one in
my in my family to go to college
and went from
air force academy into the air force
learned about nuclear missiles learned
how to fly got a top secret clearance
learned chinese it was a great air force
experience and then when i tried to
leave because i was not a short hair
clean shaven kind of guy you were not
even when you were in oh no i had to be
when i was in right so every day
was
one of those days where you're like this
is not what i want to do for the rest of
my life and when you're like 22 years
old 23 years old like every year feels
like a long time so that now we're like
years just disappear but when you're
this is the real you this is long hair
colin kaepernick vibe the beard i need
to get rattier like dreads i need to
have some sun bleach going on i want to
have that leather skin that you see so
often in florida go down to south beach
they're everywhere
i'm still endeavoring i'm still
endeavoring but that was what picked me
up so then cia saw me trying to leave
the air force and and that's ci saw you
trying to leave the air force and then
they reached out to you yeah exactly and
now let me ask you this was there a
like was there a desire to one day want
to be an fbi nsa cia was there anything
like that oh yeah absolutely i mean i
was one of those kids that grew up
wanting to be a fireman and a cop and
serve and keep people safe that's what i
always wanted to do when i graduated
from the air force academy my number one
choice we get to choose we get to tell
the air force what we want to do my
number one choice was air force
intelligence but then needs the service
it's the military so they put you
wherever they need you so they're like
well you can fly you're the right height
you had decent grades so now you're
going to be a pilot and i was like oh i
was hoping to do intel and then you know
going through my air force career it was
i wasn't the best at anything and the
air force had just told me that i
couldn't be an intelligence officer so
the last thing i was thinking as a 27
year old is that i should apply for cia
they told you you couldn't be an
intelligence officer for what reasoning
because they wanted me to be a pilot
instead okay got it so i was like i
swing you know i took my swing at bat i
got turned down not gonna keep wasting
time on this one so when i got the phone
call from langley i was like maybe you
didn't see in the records where i
already got passed up for this once or
you know interesting i learned later on
how air force actually how uh how cia
actually recruits and then it all made
sense but at the time i was thinking
i've already been flushed out of this
system like there's no reason to expect
it i'd be remiss if i didn't bring up
the fact that i saw you say something to
the effect of
you were applying or you wanted to get
into the peace corps and you had two
main things on your on your mind which
very much so it resonates with me you
wanted to see the world and you wanted
to get laid yeah and you're like all
right what what else is out there and
then something popped up on your screen
that said how is it out of hundreds of
hours of content out there that's the
only thing i mean at some at at the end
of the day some great
nonchalantly you're like yeah i got into
the air force academy like that's
nothing to shake a stick at man you have
to get two senators to sign correct me
if i'm wrong two senators to sign off
the governor to sign off like that's
nothing to shake and stick at man plus
you flew for him our 85 year old shake a
stick reference i've never heard that
from anyone 80 at heart baby 80 at heart
old souls old souls are the best uh yeah
and there's there's some challenges to
get the air force academy but being a
brown kid in pennsylvania in 1998
i mean affirmative action has its
benefits it also helped that i was a
busboy in a white like a white person's
uh
golf club where where the senator or
whether or my congressman liked to
frequent okay so i was a hard-working
busboy who actually had the ear this of
the congress person and then my bosses
backed me up they were like hey this
guy's a busboy but he's not going to be
a bus boy forever right back this kid up
back this kid up really
yeah it's all about i am i mean from my
success is not because i'm smart it's
not because i'm like lucky it's not
because i'm uh i'm anything other than
just blessed by the fact that other
people stepped up and lifted me up one
more level so so then when you when
you're in it and you're thinking well
this is not gonna work out you know air
force intelligence i'm gonna have to
figure something out
was it an immediate thing that they
contacted you because my friend he
wanted to be delta a friend of mine
wanted to be delta to become delta iv
you're not gonna be like hey
guys can you tell somebody from delta to
reach out to me i really want to be
delta you can do that with special
forces you can do that with ranger you
can do that with a lot of things
not with delta all of a sudden he's
disappeared he disappears for eight
years
and then years later i meet up with him
and madrid he says yeah i was delta the
last you know 12 or 13 years
but that was his dream from 18 when we
first got to the unit at 101st that was
his dream to go delta and it happened
was it the dream to become cia was it
the dream okay so it wasn't that part
wasn't for you yeah yeah it was never it
was never a childhood dream i've worked
with people who just like i mean fit
your story exactly yeah nine ten years
old i want to be cia went to college
picked their major did everything to get
there and then they got there yeah but
that just wasn't me for me it was what
can i do that lets me travel the world
and get laid i was i said something part
of your screen one day so i was applying
yeah when i was trying to leave the air
force
and anyone who has transitioned out of
the military knows what this feels like
you're like what the hell can i do like
in one in one way you're like the whole
world is an option and then in the other
side you're like i only do one thing in
uniform and nobody needs that out there
so in my kind of frustrated attempts to
figure out where i fit in that was when
i just boiled myself down to well what
am i like what are the things i really
want here at 27. i want to travel the
world not just the world but like the
armpit of the world i want to see the
shittiest parts of the world because i
was able to see some shitty parts of the
world with the air force and it really
made me proud to be an american
so i was like i want to see more shitty
parts of the world because it's just
going to make my confidence and my
my appreciation for my country that much
firmer so i was looking for africa i was
looking for like hardship
and i was looking for a lady with hairy
armpits and hairy legs i wanted to get
it on and attend in africa those are the
two things i was looking for peace corps
was going to deliver wow but halfway
through that application
you have
but
i won't understand how the cia works
something popped up on your screen
was that intentional or is that
accidental you know you see what i'm
asking so you gotta remember the
government works like one giant organism
and the the peace corps is part of the
government state department is part of
the government dhs is part of the
government fbi is part of the government
the u.s military is part of the
government my entire record
going back to the age of 18 was on file
my name was in capital letters which
means i'm an asset of the us government
right that's that's what they saw so
when i started applying to another
government agency
i fell into some massive algorithm
somewhere and happened to hit on what
they were looking for just like a
keyword search anywhere else got it and
i got a warning screen that popped up in
the middle of my online application to
peace corps a screen that said hey you
may qualify for other opportunities big
red screen
please put this application on hold
and we'll reach out to you within 72
hours if if you were to have the same
thing happen yeah big red screen says
hey you may qualify for other
opportunities and you're 27 years old
how how easy is it to click that button
and says yes put me on hold
and that's how that's how they found me
and then from that point forward it's
just that application was abandoned and
a new application was created so it
wasn't it's not a word of mouth uh
method of recruiting they have multiple
cia has multiple ways of recruiting
there is word of mouth for sure there's
word of mouth and that's for a very deep
cover
kind of niche area because there you
you're looking for people with
established credibility and in some
special field so
it's not easy to find business people
who are actually running successful
businesses and then you want to turn
them into spies that's that's a hard
thing to do so you look for word of
mouth and then you have things like the
government world anybody trying to move
from one government job to another
government job that can be automated
that's easy and then you've got the
whole world of college recruiting where
you have either somebody who's a
recruiter on campus or somebody who's a
regional recruiter that visits multiple
campuses and you will literally find cia
in a cheesy stall
with a sign at almost every college
recruiting event for big colleges
pat you tell the story that
your dad pulled you aside one day and
he's like
you can tell me son
it's okay just you can tell me you were
in the army
uh 101st right and your dad literally
thought
you were doing something what was that
this was five six years ago he says you
know it's five six years ago he's six
years you're already running php
this is six years ago this is maybe five
to seven years ago where he's like you
can tell me you know we have people in
the family i'm like dad i'm telling you
i'm not he says i understand if you are.
i said that first of all i'm not he says
i know even if you were you couldn't
tell me i said i'm telling you right now
i'm not so
till today there's a 20 chance
he legitimately thought you could have
been something in the intelligence
community cia what have you yeah
i don't even know where the speculation
for him can he just one day came up to
me we're having dinner and he asked me a
question he says i've been really
thinking about this i don't know how to
ask you without offending you yeah he
says are you i said i'm i'm telling you
i'm not
he says i understand and he kept saying
i understand like yeah
i'm telling you i'm not but
he's your dad man
so your dad your dad always thinks that
you're the best your dad always thinks
that you're the most elite right like
that's an awesome dad that's an awesome
pat the reality is and i'm using air
quotes you're most likely not uh an
asset but
you were at one point did you have
family members people pull you aside and
be like andy i mean
come on i mean just tell me you could i
mean i'm your dad here i'm your friend
i'm your friend yeah nobody
was was on to you do you have those
difficult questions yeah i mean honestly
just one of the things cia does train
you to do is how to look and act like
the most boring forgettable person
especially to your own family
so i didn't get a lot of those
challenges how do you do that so one of
the that doesn't look like a natural
thing for you you don't seem like a
boring you know no so how do you how do
you adjust if you're not you have my
background which is what makes me
interesting i got turned away at the
front door of your
building
they looked at me and the guy the guy no
kidding said uh what are you doing here
yeah and i said i'm here for an
interview with who yeah patrick we don't
just let anyone into this building i
need to call someone out of the way
i need to call someone because i get
somebody
something outside as i pulled in i
usually come in the back door i saw andy
in the front i was like oh that's man i
mean i know who that is
and he couldn't get in i was like come
on buddy right this way sign in please
though so that's how you do it man just
being discreet and just not someone you
know that someone would recognize so the
human brain has two has two elements to
it right it has a fight or a flight
response and it's in its paleo-mammalian
brain in the central cortex in the back
of your brain so you look at everything
around you as either beneficial or
threat
right or even to boil it down further
threat non-threat threat non-threat the
way that you get yourself forgotten you
always trigger the non-threat side of
the brain if you ever trigger the threat
side of the brain either because you're
super attractive or because you're super
ugly whichever one it is right if you
trigger that threat responsive in any
way you're going to get remembered the
brain will store that in short-term
memory move it to long-term memory just
depending on what it thinks if you
trigger the non-threat side you don't
even get retained in short-term memory
so so essentially okay so let's let's
talk about it how to be a non-threat
don't ask tough questions
don't ask technical questions don't ask
why questions don't talk about yourself
don't talk about yourself
don't touch politics don't touch world
events or those some of the ways you
correct look put together but don't look
like you put effort into yourself don't
wear your money don't wear money on your
wrist don't wear money on your fingers
don't wear money on your clothes
show up on time not early or late
um why is that because if you show up
early then people remember that because
usually you catch people by surprise
if you show up late people are usually
annoyed because they've been waiting if
you show up on time you give everyone
else a chance to either be early or late
and they feel good no matter which way
they are because either they were early
and prepared for you or they were late
and you were prepared for them which
makes them feel good interesting but
that's a little counter counterintuitive
to what i hear about the military we
have our our friend a couple friends of
the marine here chris he says if you're
on time you're late yeah that's what how
do you that's like kind of kind of
cognitive dissonance between a ci agent
and just a typical
uh
military person correct because remember
cia when you're cia you're trying to be
discreet and you're trying never to
appear as a threat you're trying to be
forgotten
when you're military you're trying to
show obedience you're trying to be
remembered
right so on time
early is on time on time is late very
very standard military jargon because
when the commander shows up the
commander wants everyone there because
who wants to feel important the
commander the commander right if you
show up after the commander's there
everybody looks at you because they
think you think you're more important
than the commander
that makes sense so going back to it
with the recruiting side hopefully we'll
get to the bottom of the story on how
you got recruited this time let's see if
we're going to get this guys okay this
time we're on so
you you apply on this you set the pop up
so you apply on this pop-up what happens
next all i did on the pop-up all i did
was click put me on pause so i'm inside
the peace corps website you know i'll
wait for 72 hours before and i'll give
someone a chance to call me about 24
hours later i get a phone call and the
phone call is to an old school flip
phone if you remember those old
yeah and all it says is 703. i don't
know what 703 is but it doesn't say
blocked it doesn't say unlisted it
doesn't say the full number it just says
703 so i pick it up on the other line is
some
nice person a lady who basically says
hey are you andrew bustamante did you
apply for this position and you know i
said yes to all those things she was
like hey it seems like you might be a
good fit for a role in national security
would that be something that interests
you and then we have a very short
conversation that basically just
verifies i am who i said i was on the on
online and that i would be interested in
national security position they don't
say who or who with did you ask i did i
said who was it with and she said we're
not in a position to disclose that right
now but she did say we would like to
interview in person in washington dc
would you be amenable to that uh and
again 27 year old 27 year old single
male everything she asked me was yes
yeah i'm down let's do it let's go so
then she said we're gonna send you a
ticket and a rental car reservation a
hotel reservation it'll be at your house
overnight and then just follow those
instructions and and we'll see you in dc
two virginia oh dc yeah so for me i'm in
i'm in montana at the time and i think
to myself
not never going to happen nothing's
going to show up that that was just a
weird crank like whatever people are
just trying stupid you legitimately
didn't think it was a real thing because
i was a nuclear missile officer for the
air force too so this just seemed to me
like uh this could have been anything it
could have been there's not a lot of me
that i'm a nuclear missile
come on guys
vinnie did the same thing he was a
nuclear
uh officer in the air force i don't
think he's as qualified as hell no but
wait a minute vinnie was a nuclear
officer in the air force vincent
o'shanna the same guy who dresses up as
alfonso ramirez and raids nancy pelosi's
office was a former nuclear missile
officer
in the air force we have to verify that
we're a cool bunch of crazies
that's true
okay so so you're in montana they send
the car you're thinking there's no way
they're someone's trying to pull a prank
on you and then i get i get an overnight
package that has everything she said it
would have with a with a physical paper
ticket that has me in dc like two months
later
and i go and i go and i follow
everything the recruiting process
recruiting process kicks off now for
most people that recruiting process is
somewhere between nine and 18 months
because it takes so long for the
security clearance to come through i
already had the clearance so my my
interview process happened in about six
months not because again not because i
was smart but just because
the majority of the work was done they
had my whole military background they
knew that i was a chinese speaker
they knew i had nuclear missile uh
knowledge and they knew that i was uh
and they knew that i was now let me ask
you you say because i'm not smart are
you right you know how sometimes we're
kind of like well i'm not the smartest
guy you know exactly we're kind of
playing that i'm not that smart to not
be a threat because we want to be not a
threat and you're naturally transparent
multiple times
yeah this air force nuclear scientist
over here not that smart yeah but no but
but the part a part of
that is for me
i don't know if i want cia to not
recruit
smart people like you i don't want them
to go recruit like just anybody off the
street so
you know there's there's a when you when
i worked out morgan stanley dean witter
they we went through a bunch of
interview process of course nothing like
it in military you didn't go through
interview pro i was a hammer mechanic so
you don't become a hammer mechanic
needing a process just here's a wrench
go right
but when when i did go through morgan
stanley dean what it was like one
interview two interview you're not
accustomed to dominating interviews and
you're taking tests after test after
test after test after test what were
some of the tests you took with them was
it
more mental no i'm assuming none of it
was probably physical because if you're
coming from air force they already know
you're somewhat taking care of yourself
what were some of the tests you went
through yeah so it's a psychological
battery it's a it's a psychological
battery almost exclusively so i had a
2.4 gpa coming out of college which is
well below what they say you have to
have to apply to cia they say you have
to have a minimum of 3.5
and then i went on and got a graduate
degree at university of south florida
and i did i did well in my graduate
studies mainly because i wanted to prove
to myself that i was smarter than i was
in college i was just chasing tail in
college and we all suck grade grade-wise
when you spend late nights on benders
and tail
but
the application process for cia looks
like personal interviews where they're
basically pressure testing your ability
to work under fire and and be flexible
with the situation and then they pair
that with psychological interviews some
of those psychological interviews or
some of those psychological tests test
your personality
others test your
your cognitive reasoning other ones
actually quantify your ability to take
disparate information and then combine
it into something useful so i did well i
must have done well enough in those
tests to be moved forward but i didn't
expect at any point to actually make it
to the next round because in my in the
back of my head i'm thinking
like i was i barely graduated college
yeah granted i went to a nice college i
went to a challenge in college but i
still didn't get great grades and i
wasn't a 4.0 student in high school i am
i am the
the model uh get distracted by things
fun and life kind of person just turns
out after i got in that is exactly what
cia is looking for the undercover
element of cia the directorate of
operations the national clandestine
service the people whose job it is to go
out there meet and recruit as sources
and spies
those people need to be
flexible social and up for the next big
adventure
your analysts
your scientists your tech wizards you
need those people
are super smart and borderline
uh asperger's they don't always want to
go outside they don't want to deal with
people hardcore introverts great point
that that do a different job that
totally makes sense so it makes sense
where
uh
it is almost the non-threat as well it's
a form of a non-threat based on how
you're explaining it okay so
then you go in your your uh
said six months ago because you already
had the clearance so you're hired you're
working with them uh at this point are
you moving somewhere are you staying
where you are are you constantly on the
road what are you telling your parents
did you have a girlfriend at the time if
you did what did you tell her like what
was what were those conversations like
yeah i mean those are man no one has
asked me these questions brother these
are i i'm i'm enjoying and mildly
uncomfortable by somebody i had a great
girlfriend at the time who i hope does
not follow me anymore because this
interview is going to hurt her heart for
sure but i had a great girlfriend she
was a great girl and and she was in
montana with me we were both nuclear
missile officers and i got the call to
come out and in that first interview
that's when they tell you you're being
considered for cia you're being
considered for undercover work at this
point you can't tell anybody you're
going to work for cia but you can tell
them that you're considering government
positions and that you're flying to
washington dc for these multiple
interviews as someone looking for
government positions
and then they tell you very clearly you
need to start breaking off contact with
anyone you don't intend to spend the
rest of your life with oh damn so
that's exactly what i did i went back
and she was a great girlfriend but she
wasn't someone i was going to spend the
rest of my life with so i had to start
breaking off that contact even before i
knew i was going to the second or third
interview i knew peace corps was my
future she wasn't applying to the peace
corps i knew that something around the
world something you know
hard was my future she was looking for
something different yeah so i had to
leave that behind well they say like a
lot of in the manosphere red pill
community they say chase excellence not
women it sounded that's like exactly
what you were doing yeah and i didn't i
wouldn't give myself the credit to say
that but it does feel right when you say
it out loud like that right
um and then my mom and dad i come from a
family that was my family was in the
middle of a divorce my mom and dad were
at 25 years of marriage and then going
through divorce that was their thing it
was the perfect
the perfect chaos for me to not even be
in a blip on their radar so hey guys i'm
sorry about your divorce i'm going to
leave the military and go get a job in
the government you have brothers and
sisters i have two two younger sisters
one was having a baby the other one was
figuring out her own life like it was
really easy
when you when you want to disappear you
would be shocked how easy it is to
disappear everybody's living in their
own world and once it once someone just
opens your eyes to the fact that every
we are all the star of our own movie
that movie is our life we are the star
we are the hero we are the center of
attention except when you sit next to
somebody else you realize
they're the star of their movie i'm not
even a supporting actor in their movie
they don't even know i'm here so when
you just stop talking when you just stop
talking about yourself when you stop
trying to get attention it's really easy
to have no one give you attention pat
let me ask you you talk about this all
the time like you disappeared for a
while you cut off all your friends you
said i gotta change my life this
happened after your dad had a heart
attack i mean you i allegedly not in the
cia so different stories here but
not everybody watching here is trying to
get part of the cia but
disappearing and recreating yourself
that's something you talk about all the
time pat would you weigh in on that yeah
i mean it's it but but in this example
which is very
the way he's explaining it is the fact
that even when you disappear most people
are not going to notice when you
disappear correct you know there's only
a few people that can disappear by the
way even sometimes big names disappear
you don't even know about it like jack
ma nobody barely even noticed the one by
choice versus by force he's disappeared
not because he's trying to be a
hide-and-go-seek champion he disappeared
because i think they disappeared
yeah but
that is a big thing you talk about
recreating yourself and disappearing
well it's the count account of monte
cristo right when a guy disappears he
goes to jail comes out reads all these
books that mentor yes comes out his girl
leaves him for this other guy and all of
us and he's putting the party the girl
shows up wait a minute and i'd recognize
the face that movie is a very very deep
movie so
here you disappear now are you in
communication are they hearing from you
are they seeing you is there christmas
parties are you going to family
gatherings are you going to thanksgiving
dinner are you still doing those types
of things yeah so i'm doing i'm doing
the bare minimum to kind of stay a
member of the family so that i don't
become a threat by ostracizing the
family i'm just
i'm i'm the son that has an important
government job somewhere and if you talk
to most most parents
won't be able to tell you the details of
what their kids do they'll say oh i
think he's a salesman for some insurance
company or oh i think he's a he's a
doctor in a practice in you know tampa
whatever it might be they don't know the
details so it's very easy for my family
my sisters my cousins everyone what
would you tell them i work for the
government and then
i can't think that your families don't
ask what do you do for the government so
i would tell them i worked in the
foreign service
what does that mean so foreign service
is a subset of multiple government
agencies that work overseas
right so there's there's foreign service
and support fbi there's foreign service
and support department of state there's
foreign services that support trade and
commerce there's there's the foreign
service is a sub element of the us
government that basically is americans
serving abroad have a hard time
believing that nobody else would go a
little bit deeper than that with the
questions they do but okay they do but
you don't one of the things that we're
taught to do when you're undercover is
you don't you you turn questions
so if somebody starts digging into me
here's here's
you wanna you wanna disappear you don't
talk about you you wanna appear as a
non-threat you don't talk about you so
when they ask you a question you just
turn the question around to let them
talk about them
how do you do that give us an example
because pat basically saying yeah
foreign service come on buddy what does
that mean yeah so foreign service so so
what does that mean what does that look
like and i'd be like oh just means that
i get to travel the world have you ever
wanted to travel the world
and then most people will answer that
question porcupine and just flip it on
them yep where do you want to go i would
love to go there yeah yeah
so you said the shittiest places and
what's the shittiest place you went to
so kinshasa
democratic republic of congo is about as
shitty as the world game western
portland because we have a phone only
at least portland has beer shout out to
will
yeah that's an inside joke between only
five of us so i ask people all the time
like if you had millions of dollars and
you were quote unquote chilling what do
you want to do with your free time
everyone says travel the world but
nobody wants to go to shitty places
you had this yearning to see the worst
of the worst of the worst hairy armpits
hairy armpits so you could sort of
codify your love for america how did
that even resonate with your mind it
wasn't necessarily codifying so when i
was with the air force academy they sent
me to china so i was on a i was learning
chinese and in 2002 2002 i went to china
to do a six-week language immersion with
the with the air force academy and when
i was there
it was i've been to canada i'd been to
resorts in mexico like i've done the
stuff that most americans do but in
china
i was eating dog
i was really i could yeah it's a it's a
normal meat to eat there what about bat
i didn't have bat that's less normal
yeah you were eating dogs yeah we ate we
ate dog meat right we there are there
are stands street stalls just like you
would get a hot dog in new york really
with scorpions and like uh different
large beetles like this is just normal
stuff there right and then it's it looks
like new york but the food stalls are
not anything like we've ever seen i
can't drink the water the water out of
the sink can't be used to brush your
teeth the water that comes out of a
water fountain when you go to a
restaurant you always have to ask for
the bottles of water like these were
little things where i was like i don't
have to do this in america like i can
literally go to any sink in the united
states
and like grab a glass and drink some
water yeah it might taste bad but it's
not actually going to give me a
long-term permanent gastrointestinal
issue you're not going to have
montezuma's revenge yeah so just these
things when i when i finally left china
to come back to the united states and i
landed in the united states i was like
oh this feels good so why would you want
more of that and even worse because one
thing that i've always been is very
proud of of my country and it gives me
the ability to drown out the noise
there's so much noise in our country so
much what i call first world problems
people bitching and complaining and
fighting
about things that give that make us inc
a half a percent .01 percent better or
worse than where we were yesterday not
realizing we're 35 percent better than
other first world countries i took my
executive assistant with me on a trip
recently to
uh to
austria and we went to australia to
support like ukrainian refugee program
and whatever else it was awesome
excellent food excellent booze excellent
people beautiful surroundings the
buildings were pristine very very
heavily socialist country right we come
back to the united states we cross the
border in orlando you know what she says
it's so good to be back in america
i was like [ __ ] yes that is exactly
right that's why you want to travel the
world you're just going to get to that
conclusion a whole lot faster in third
world countries than in first that is a
very good point by the way especially as
a uh uh i saw your you you you and your
uh daughter your
daughter right did you have a daughter
you and your daughter were sitting there
she was doing homework or studying world
or wars or different things and just
watching how you're raising your kid as
well uh have you taken your your
daughter yet to a third world world
country and if yes which one was it so
my children have not been to a third
world country they've lived in the
united arab emirates they lived in abu
dhabi got it for a year got it um and my
son especially they both have very fond
memories and uae is a first world
country because it's a khaliji arab
country
rich in oil wealth yeah they basically
overnight developed into a first world
country so it's not a difficult life at
all it's except for the heat
and
the culture right arab culture is a
difficult culture when you're westerner
my kids have very fond memories but they
also are like it's not like like i don't
want to go back to uae this is something
they tell me often i don't want to go
back to the desert i like the fact that
i can you know be free to talk to
whoever i want to talk to i don't have
to worry if they're a girl or a boy i
don't have to worry about classes
they're saying that at what age
my son is nine my daughter is fine i
love that i love that basic stuff there
so okay let's let's go back to being a
ci agent so what what can you talk about
that you were a par i've had a lot of ci
agents here
uh we've had jonah mendes on which uh
you know achieved this guy's office i
think she was married to tony mendez
another story like you guys were they
were also married
to each other nick mckinley we can go to
mike baker we can go to so many of them
and it's
it's such a interesting space right on
what you guys do and then sometimes like
i remember one time i was hosting a
vistage event i don't know if you're
familiar with vistage vistage is a
community for c-suite executives and
every month ceos come together and
there's a chair and then he brings a
guest uh once every other month one of
the guests we brought to our office was
the former director of one of the
directors of ci for a region of it that
he came to us
pretty powerful guy well-known guy
but he came up and for one hour we kept
asking questions
and his answer was i can talk about that
i can't talk about that i can't talk
about that i can't talk about that what
can you talk about that you
uh uh were involved in not necessarily
details but to say i participated in
this i was a part of this and i was a
part of this so the rules at cia are
interesting because i and i i love my ca
brothers and sisters who are still
serving and everyone who's former and
they know that this is true
we can talk about a whole hell of a lot
more than what we choose to talk about
it's just there's a culture
older gray hairs have a culture that
they grew up in where you just talk less
they've taken it too far so they've
taken it so far that now they appear
cagey and now they appear like they're
trying to hide something when the cia
doesn't ask you to hide anything the
only thing cia tells you to do
officially is to protect sources and
methods interesting classified sources
of collecting information classified
methods to collect information
everything else is fair game for the
most part with the exception of speaking
in detail about where you served so i
can say i was all over asia i was i was
i was often working in latin america i
was often working in the middle east i
was often working in africa
i can tell you that i can tell you some
regions right you don't have to stretch
your brain if you know that i speak
chinese i also speak tai again i can
tell you what i speak you have to infer
the rest from there what i can't tell
you is what kind of operation what kind
of sources what kind of methods i was
using to collect information that the
policy policymakers needed every one of
us can talk about that nick can talk
about that i know nick nick's a good
dude right he's running a fantastic
operation with deliver fund doing great
things he can talk about that if he
chooses to right jonah does a pretty
good job of talking about some of her
background but she didn't she wasn't
operational she was in the disguise
space she was what we call support on
our side really interesting stories she
can talk a whole lot more than what she
talks about she can't tell you exactly
how we create our prosthetics and she
can't tell you what adhesives we use to
make sure that they stick in cold and
hot weather and through sweat but she
can talk about a lot more than she
chooses to talk about we all can so from
from maybe let me ask a question this
way and by the way is it true that you
guys sign a lifelong nda that's a
lifelong nda it's not an nda it's a
secrecy agreement yeah it's a secrecy
agreement so okay so let's say you break
it what happens if you break it what do
we do as soon as we break it that gives
cia the the legal jurisdiction to uh to
arrest us for breaking a law right
however we still have a court of our
peers that we have to go to this is
where it gets tricky this is kind of the
loophole in the whole process this is
what makes it so that people write
memoirs that the cia never approves but
those same people never really go to
jail in order for cia to prove to a
public court that you disclose
classified information
they have to disclose the classified
information to the court
so if you say
like if you write a book and you're like
i was an undercover officer in iraq
technically you just broke your secrecy
agreement so cia can come out and say
now you're going to jail you we can sue
you for breaking the secrecy agreement
but then they have to present the court
with documents that show
that you were actually in iraq so
there's no secrecy agreement then
there's a secrecy agreement if you go
too far
has anybody ever gone too far nobody's
gone too far people have had lots of
different punishments that can be done
through different types of court but
people don't people have yet to go to
jail for
disclosing information without a an
intelligence service or disclosing
information to a foreign government is
there a different method of this
discipline that we're not aware of that
you guys can't talk about
uh we can talk about yeah so the the
other methods of discipline are that we
can have wages get garnered often so i'm
working i've worked on two book projects
my first book projects made it all the
way through approval processes and
everything was ready to go to publishers
until
a civilian attorney got involved and
decided that they wanted to have an
extra conversation with cia and then
that extra conversation cia was like oh
you know what we don't want this book to
go public so we're going to say no
after they had said yes to all these
other things
when they communicated that to me the
way that they said it is we know that
we've approved for this book to go live
we know that we've already proved
everything you've said about you but we
have not approved what the what this
other person who's involved in the book
said about themselves so if you go live
with this book they'll go to jail
okay so but let's let's stay on that so
in order for a person to fully follow
those guidelines there has to be a
public example of what can happen if you
really cross the line
has
do you understand what i'm saying like
if there's not a public example it's
like yeah but listen
i kind of know how to work uh in between
the lines to still get my message across
and i'm having this conversation here or
there
you know
like even you know the mob right the mob
is like hey we have omerta hey and i've
sat with god knows how many people in
the mob world i've interviewed
you know it's a in the mob
if you go through emerita you may get
killed your family may pay a price for
it so it's the price is even bigger but
the cia is not going to say if you do
anything
andy we're going to come after your your
son and your daughter and your wife and
you know they can't say that right to
you right so
what is bigger than taking your life the
garnishing wages i don't give a [ __ ] if
you garnish my way just let's just say
if i'm going through it if i'm cia
that's not that scary right the only
thing that's really that scary
is family blood and other things that i
don't get to do because you're
professional at uh at hiding it's not
like they're putting a chip in you where
if you decide to go live in a place if
you really wanted to hide you could hide
away from cia couldn't you uh you could
try yeah we have the skills to try and
to do a pretty good job of it but if
they were to really use all of their
resources they'd find pretty much
anybody so what's been a method where
they've done something where other
people are
scared to not want to follow through
with that
so i think it's there's two things here
right so first i would say that you
don't have i would disagree with your
first point that you have to have a
public example of punishment to convince
people not to do something you actually
don't need a public punishment you just
need to state and demonstrate some level
of
high probability that something might
happen
most people are motivated by fear
fear true fear is a future state
so if they just instill enough fear fear
is something that controls behavior
so if you're coming from cia i mean matt
put yourself in the shoes of a person
who has committed part of their life to
working for this organization and then
they leave
and then they start writing a book or
they start speaking out they start
coming on podcasts whatever it might be
they don't want to run the risk of
crossing a boundary too far
and then actually forcing the hand of
the federal government you don't want to
be that person because you're in in my
heart i'm still very proud of serving
the last thing i want to do
going to jail isn't the worst thing
having my wages garnered isn't the worst
thing
losing the respect of the same
organization that i served losing the
respect of the american people who i
love
that's that's
worse
than sitting in a jail cell yeah but
that's your character that's not
everyone's character that's a lot of our
characters the people i left keep in
mind i left
i had my first child and i left
many people have many children and stay
many people sacrifice their
relationships multiple divorces they
sacrifice their health they sacrifice
their fitness they sacrifice everything
to continue to serve
for me and my wife at 2014 came and we
had to make a life decision and we
decided to prioritize family first now
you were exactly right that's 2016 on
massive attrition from the intelligence
services we were at the front end of it
but what they've seen since 2016 is
incredible and we were at the we didn't
start the trend we just happened to be
on the first wave of leaving but you you
left like at the pres it's like selling
your property at a perfect time you sold
at a perfect time and we're very happy
of it too yeah oh i mean congratulations
on selling your property at a perfect
time so so okay fair enough so
i asked that because you know you said
fear is a great motivator of what
actions we take in the future i get it
but i also thinks you know
uh uh you know sometimes also when you
learn a lot
you
you know the three phases we all go
through with parents and kids right your
first phase you know kids idolize their
parents
then second phase they demonize their
parents oh i saw what you did that you
know mom i said they demonize then third
phase is they humanize their parents
right i'm assuming an agent a cia agent
or an fbi on nsa probably goes through
those three phases with the agency as
well
you first idolize like two others you're
like oh my god
and the cia that's sick that for oh my
i'd be using that to get late every day
you know that's what i'd be doing right
so i'm assuming like phase one is dude
i'm idolizing i'm part of the freaking
cia and second phase like damn that's
some dirty stuff right there cause
there's stuff you know that we don't
know right so then you demonize
then you humanize and you say well these
are not perfect people everybody makes
mistakes and every organization makes
mistake corporations make mistakes
governmental agencies make mistakes etc
etc so you go more in the humanizing
phase but while somebody's in the
demonizing phase
and they're seeing the dark side of the
organization
that's that's a vulnerable area for
somebody to come in and exploit that
opportunity absolutely okay and many
have from the outside right many we've
had agents that have
been bought money sex women all of that
stuff
for me when it says a lifelong type of
an india you call it secrecy
you know i don't know it's like
sometimes i wonder if it's happening we
don't know about it but they can't talk
about it because it'll ruin the
credibility of the existing agency
because how do some people know so much
about us
where are they getting there until like
you were talking about how russia on
another podcast you were talking about
how great of a job russia has done
uh against ukraine how they're actually
getting exactly what they want yes you
know
ukraine has shown a lot of strength but
maybe russia's
strategy is working very effectively how
they're getting their intel i don't know
even you said you said i don't know how
they're getting
how they're doing what they're doing so
how are they doing it maybe
we have some people that are supporting
them could that be a possibility i would
say it's more than a possibility it's
almost a guarantee okay that we that the
united states in the world of
intelligence we all
assume
that we are penetrated to some level or
or another right penetrated means we
have a mole
among us or we have information leaks
among us there's a technical operation
collecting information from servers or
databases somewhere right you have to
assume
that you're compromised
because if you assume that you're not
compromised you're even more exposed to
risk
so assume that your compromise
compartment compartmentalize from there
and act appropriately increase your
security from there right just like i
joked about the guy who didn't let me in
the front door that's awesome security
for valuetainment this building is that
much more secure because that guy in in
the face of doubt kept me out no problem
he let me in eventually guys getting a
promotion by the way
but that's that's how you have to
operate if you want to maximize security
right when it comes to why we don't
speak out of school yeah we don't want
to dishonor our country we don't want to
dishonor cia we don't want to smear our
family names but we also for damn sure
don't want to give our enemies
information they might be able to use
against us just so that we can talk
about it on cnn or talk about it in the
press there's an awesome example of
osama bin laden from
from 2000
to 2003 the washington
the wall street times or maybe the new
york times wall street journal in new
york times
was speaking to
as a
intelligence service anonymous source
and they talked about how we were
tracking bin laden through his satellite
phone
that that was a source and a method
right the one thing we're not supposed
to talk about and then because of that
bin laden stopped using that satellite
phone completely changed his
communication strategy went dark went
black and we had to start all over again
i don't want to give
china
any advantages i don't want to give
russia any advantages i want to give the
american people every advantage we can
give them but i also want to be able to
talk honestly about what my peers don't
talk about because just like you're
saying i want to respect my secrecy
agreement but i also want to be able to
shed some additional perspective on the
awesome work that the men and women
still inside get to do
the privilege that i have as an american
being able to leave and still talk about
it because if i was in france i wouldn't
be able to if i was in china i wouldn't
be able to if you're a sbr officer in
russia once you leave you don't get to
talk about it
that's that's uh
that's good that you're so pro-american
okay and and i love hearing that but for
me i want to transition into this next
topic and then we can talk about the one
that i skipped over
um
so peter strzok okay james comey james
comey parties with hillary clinton and
bill clinton his wife they've supported
their campaign okay
peter strzok hey texts come out this is
what we're willing to do xyz
you know there's no way we're gonna let
him win you know and the texts we can
see the text right okay you seem like a
reasonable guy you seem like a nice guy
you seem like a uh guy
that you're like a trifecta
i would have a blast having party with
you go and partying with you and we were
20s we'd have a blast together if we
added it maybe we'd go to jail but we'd
still have a blast together
number two you're the kind of guy that i
you know enjoy watching a game with and
we're sitting there talking and you know
and then three i feel comfortable for my
family and my kids to meet you and we
you know you go to the house bring you
to my place you give that vibe okay
you're a man's man you give very peace
comfort all that stuff
i can't say that about everybody and we
can't say that the ci is a hundred
percent bulletproof hiring process
because you can't read in the minds of
everyone and i understand how some
people that are fully non-emotional that
can be also psychological where a person
can be
extremely narcissistic or whatever they
can manipulate that's probably not a
person they want to hire as well
but how do people like peter struck how
do people like that get in
where they represent an institution that
we have to trust an agency that's
essentially working to protect me
how do
they
prevent from their emotions
and their friendships and the parties
they get invited to
and the communities they live in
how do they say listen we may be best
friends i may support you but you're
going to jail okay that's a very hard
thing for a person to do once you're
fully vested with someone right there's
a reason how they say in hollywood a lot
of big celebrities they don't go on
social media if you notice the big names
they are not on twitter
you can't find a daniel day lewis on
twitter you can't find any of these big
actors on twitter because for them is
the moment we open our mouth and give
you our opinions it's very hard for us
to act because now you see us in a
certain way right okay
that's very deep to me very like this
guy that played the elvis presley i
don't know what the guy's name is
incredible job i was watching all his
interviews i was so flabbergasted by the
guy i was really blown but there's
nothing on the guy right how what kind
of an artist he is
but for this side
i have a hard time believing that even
these agents on the inside can let their
emotions get in a way where they help
one side of the political party over the
other side no it is again let's if we
skip the
idolized phase and we skip the demonized
phase we go straight to humanize phase
that's you're you're explaining exactly
why that happens
of course they're swayed by their
emotions we're all swayed by our
emotions we go through specific training
to to
de
de-incentivize our emotional
decision-making and increase our
dependence on rational decision-making
but it's still a process it has to be
trained it has to be practiced it has to
be exercised
oftentimes when you're making emotional
decisions you're not giving yourself
space or time to train or exercise
you're just in a moment making an
emotional decision that's a very human
thing to do
we all do it
i don't know uh peter peter strzok so i
don't know him personally i can't speak
to his specific credentials whether he
was blue badge cia green badge cia
related to c i have no idea what his
role was there but what i do know is the
men and women inside cia when i was fbi
but peter struck as fbi thank you very
much so when i was inside
federal government
inside specifically inside cia
where we are always taught to expect and
predict that we will think and act
emotionally and then try and take steps
to limit that so that we can give
ourselves the space to let our rational
brain keep up if you're interested in
the cognitive cycle i can give it in
about two minutes go forward so every
human brain we call it we call it pink
matter it's like a computer in your head
you have two sides the left side and the
right side we all know that what we
don't know is that one side works faster
than the other side right your your left
brain is your logical brain your right
brain is your creative or emotional
brain your right brain works faster than
your left brain
it's because your right brain depends on
these things called cognitive biases or
cognitive
connections
these inferences that it builds over
time so that it can jump from conclusion
to conclusion skipping logic that's why
if you're a if you're a butt guy
right you don't even you just you are
attracted or not attracted in an instant
based off of the thing that you're
interested in right if you're a girl
that likes a certain kind of shoe or
certain kind of purse you're attracted
to it immediately your brain is skipping
the logical step if your right brain if
your left brain was in charge it would
say what is that is it real how much
does it cost can i get access to it
that's four steps compared to the one
step that says i like it i want it
sales people understand this
intrinsically even though they may not
be able to put words to it make it so
that it triggers a right brain reaction
and the sales process will move faster
if you're trying to sell through a left
brain process the sales cycle is going
to move slower try to talk about the
features and benefits whatever else so
they train us to slow down our right
brain and speed up our left brain and
there's exercises and practices you can
do that it's one of the things that i
teach my my executives now and one of
the things i teach my sales teams now so
that people can
kind of reprogram the pink matter for me
uh uh
by the way can we do a poll can we do a
poll
uh uh to see which
which agency people trust the most put
fbi
put cia what else you want to add to it
do you want to say put nsa there as well
which of those three do you trust the
most cia i have in this i have an
assumption which one i think is going to
be number one
but just put it in there i don't want to
say it before people put it so fbi cia
nsa let's see what people say in this
poll but okay so um
that's that's my discomfort so for me
when you're working like okay last night
we're having dinner and we're talking
consulting our consulting business has
grown very rapidly
and we're getting more and more uh
uh
consultants that are coming over to us
and we're getting more people that are
calling us from mckinsey's guard you
know these bigger account consulting
firms that want to sell our product
right so they're reaching out to us one
of the things that a guy was talking
about how is a lot of lazy executives
nowadays in fortune 500 companies
they have an idea that they want to
bring up to the ceo okay so when they
want to bring up this idea to the ceo
and tom's talking about this last night
they say the best bet is i'll go to
mckenzie
and i'll say here's my idea here's a
half a million dollars can you
send me an analysis on why this idea is
good or bad they send it to them and
they'll say here's why it's a good idea
then they'll go pitch it to their ceo or
whoever the bosses that they're working
with and they'll say here's my idea by
the way i've already spent the half a
million with mackenzie mckenzie already
approved that it's a good idea let's go
ahead and test it so that's their
insurance policy to say
if it succeeds awesome i get the victory
but if it fails look at least i went and
got my insurance policy from who from
mckenzie and mckenzie gave me
a thumbs up hey you're doing a good job
go for it you know kind of like backing
them up don't worry we'll take the blame
forward because of our and whatever
research that we gave you so it's an
interesting way of doing it so for me
intelligence do i trust the government
agency
that's been there for years to do it or
would i rather use an independent agency
that's more on the free market free
enterprise side that has a reputation
that if you don't hit it negative
reviews is actually hurts a private
agency
negative views doesn't do [ __ ] for cia i
can't go on yelp and find cia i can't go
on glassdoor and find cia i can't go
anywhere and do anything with fbi and
they're like dude say whatever you want
you can't do nothing about it so
maybe what happens with this with my
opinion is
even if i'm a president that gets
elected say i become a president
do i really trust a guy that's been an
agent for 22 years because in a way the
agent that's been there for 22 years or
27 years or the director that's been
there for 32 years he looks down at me
because in the back of his head he'll
say things like
dude you're only here for four years at
best if you're lucky maybe eight years
you ain't [ __ ] i've been here for 32
years who the hell are you you're going
to come and put it on your resume that
you become a president you're out of
here i don't care what you're going to
be doing so me as a president who gets
paid to be paranoid i sit there and i
say why the hell would i trust you to do
the intelligence for me because your
loyalties to people that came before me
i'm gonna go use an independent agency
outside not in the government because i
don't trust you to be honest with you
and then see what we can get so
do you see how there's a little bit of
that you know
distrust and the lack of respect a the
director of cio or director of fbi has
for whoever becomes a president and how
the lack of trust a president could have
for people that are currently in these
agencies yeah and you're exactly right
that that is what happens and then but
there's a second step that i think we're
overlooking because all of those
director positions are presidential
appointments
so i would say almost to a worse
detriment the president just brings in
whoever he wants to put in or whoever
she wants to put in and they become the
new director
right every president has the right to
appoint who they want and that's why
that's why uh that's why directors at
cia and directors at fbi and directors
are gonna say change so frequently
because they don't come up from the
inside they don't spend 35 years at cia
and become the director they spend 35
years and become some lackey to the
director and the director is appointed
by the president inside the president's
inner circle of friends or peers and
then they get the chop off from the
senate
so even i would say it's almost worse
than what you're saying because the most
professional person in that organization
doesn't even have a chance of becoming
the director they have to make friends
with whoever the incoming president is
or even worse whoever the presidential
party represents
and then they will become nominated for
that role
and so that's the truth of how it works
and then to your second point which i
think is even more powerful america is
asking itself the question now should we
privatize intelligence
we we failed massively on september 11
2001. massive intelligence failure
because we let the
the intelligence infrastructure at fbi
and cia run things the way they had
always run things through the cold war
and we had completely closed our eyes to
the fact that we were moving into a war
on terror afghanistan massive failure
predicting ukraine massive failure right
and now with 2016 president trump when
the cia turned his back on trump trump
just dried up funding and directed this
funding into a private intelligence
organization so we have seen it work
we've seen people do it the precedent
has been set so now the government is
asking itself the question collectively
do we even keep doing it this way how do
we change how do we evolve how do we
evolve closer to the speed of business
and less to the speed of government it's
not going to happen though it's not
going to happen it's going to happen
that's why you see private intelligence
on the rise right now most of the people
that sit inside cia headquarters aren't
government employees they're contractors
that belong to booz allen hamilton
raytheon later i'm more comfortable with
that
but but that's the transition yeah i'm
more comfortable with that and i'm glad
i hope it goes that direction
uh uh uh so so
uh
my paranoia if i'm in there and even if
we appoint the director of cia okay what
percentage of the guys that are on the
inside forget about the director of ci
what percentage of the guys on the
inside that are actually doing the leg
work
that are bringing up the report to the
top
are getting replaced with a new
president not many of them and you're
and you're right again that's where
again if you if you look at it through
the humanized lens
the way that you get those people to
fall in line is you have to incentivize
them the right way
but i don't even want it to be incentive
because i i i uh
i don't want it to be incentive i like
okay in sales i understand like like the
best thing that john amanda said to me
was a follow and i said what's the
quality of a great ci agent
she said uh tyler we can hear you type
she said somebody that
is extremely charming
somebody that can pull information out
somebody who is very competitive
somebody who is very curious but when
they save the world they have no desire
to share that big victory with anybody
and they keep it to themselves like to
the level of the ambition isn't hey dude
you won't even believe what i just did
yesterday i prevented world war iii yeah
that part doesn't happen because to most
people in sales in hollywood and sports
hey so tell us lebron 38 points 16
rebounds 12 assists three steals how's
it feel well let me tell you you know
it's a form of a recognition ci agent so
tell us andy seagen busamatis how does
it feel known when you went in there
with xi jin and you found that the
china's doing this well this was a team
effort and we've been working on getting
into you don't have that kind of
recognition right so
i don't want there to be incentive
the only incentive i want anybody
working for the government is the truth
that is the only incentive that's that's
not the only incentive you want what are
the incentive do i want the form of
recognition because the the thing is no
so i never said recognition was the
incentive you said the incentive i said
they have to be incentivized but what so
how do you incentivize the same way you
incentivize career any career that's
totally fine with me that's what i'm
saying oh i'm getting with that yeah you
won't again you want the person in
charge yeah of africa operations yeah to
be the most qualified most experienced
person who's done the most hard work
who's done the most whatever to become
the head of africa and then you want to
incentivize that person to tell the
truth to the director every time so then
you don't want to make it punitive you
don't want to make it some kind of weird
uh
you know you only brief up good news and
you hide bad news you don't want that to
happen so you have to incentivize them
to continue with their career even when
they tell you what you don't want to
hear yeah so for example like you know
we're we're studying uh uh i'm not i
don't believe in art okay like i believe
70 of art is fraud okay i don't know
that it's fraud but i don't i don't
understand it so i'm with you there well
check this out so i so but i'm but i'm
so skeptical that i i did research okay
and we're sitting there going through
this stuff with art right where today
total uh value of art in the world is
1.7 trillion dollars okay and deloitte
says that by 2026 it's gonna increase by
900 billion dollars and there's a place
in switzerland called
geneva freeport that holds a hundred
billion dollars of art
1.2 million pieces they hold a hundred
billion dollars in one building you may
want to show this building that's the
building that building in geneva
freeport holds one point uh holds a
hundred billion dollars of art in that
one building okay
and this is people that buy the art that
send it there who never see the art to
prevent from paying the taxes and it's a
form of a vault so they don't buy it
because i'm going to show it off at my
house they buy it as an investment
purpose they put it in a lot of times
what a lot of billionaires and
millionaires will do is they'll buy an
art at a half a million dollars they'll
send it there they'll get a new
appraisal to say it's worth 10 million
dollars and then they'll give that art
and donate to a museum and they get a 10
million auto write-off where they get to
write off 30 of it so there's a lot of
different things with art but i'm really
trying to see maybe pat you ought to
give the people in the art world a break
so even this uh salman mundy thing that
recently sold
no no
salvador dali
you can pull up the piece that the art
piece that sold for
uh 450 million dollars recently
the guy from saudi arabia that bought it
uh leonardo d what is it called uh
salvador mullen
salvador mundi so this thing in 1958
sold for 45 pounds
then in 2005 it sells for 2 000 that
sells for ten thousand dollars in new
orleans
then a person comes out and says this
was part of
you know the queen of england's
collection and it's a real piece of
leonardo and etc etc
next thing you know it sells for 450
million dollars by a person that nobody
knows about right so and then like
80 chance it's a fake and it's not real
so i really want to debate myself on
this i really want to
convince myself
that the cia and the fbi and these
organizations do a lot of good
where the net net positive you know it's
a net positive than a net negative i'm
okay with
well i'm not looking for perfection
right but i want to be able to trust it
but man it's very very hard to do with
the last few years on what's happened my
level of skepticism it's so hard it's
hard to believe
how much good they do rather than how
much bad they do to the world
i i can understand i can totally
understand and i don't
i wouldn't disagree that i am also
disappointed with what i've seen in the
last uh since i left in 2014. so what is
that eight years
um there's a couple of things that are
you brought up two points right you
brought up your own uh questions about
the the productivity and the
constructive use of the intelligence
services and then you brought up the art
thing as i think as a parallel
this has a very interesting
story or a very interesting explanation
if you if we can get to it i think you'd
like it but when it comes to the the
value of intelligence services
it's hard to assess the value when you
only see the cost of goods sold right
that's essentially what you're looking
at what the american people look at with
any secret organization they only see
what they do wrong
they only see the things they that costs
money they have no idea the lives that
are saved they have no idea the tragedy
that's avoided they don't get those
stories
i i love jonah she's a she's a great a
great lady a great patriot a great cia
officer
but she embellishes
sometimes what it's like to be a cia
that's an old school tactic we like to
overreach
in in our our gray hairs always
overreach and i die and and uh idolize
what it's like to be cia part of it's
because that's how they were conditioned
while they were there
part of it's because they always want to
be pitching people back right the more
accurate the more accurate way of saying
it she was right about the curiosity and
she was right about the competition she
was right about all that but we
absolutely celebrate our victories we
just don't do it publicly
we have margarita machines inside cia
we'll shut down offices for half a day
we'll put them on skeleton crews just so
we can celebrate the fact that we just
avoided a civil war in
niger right absolutely those high fives
all the time people will sit in a
bullpen we have a bullpen not too
different from this and you'll sit
together with a few people overseas and
be like holy [ __ ] guys i think we just i
think we just literally saved 10
american lives today we just brought
down a terrorist cell that no one even
knows existed without any specifics how
many times does that happen in your
seven year career when you were there in
my it happened probably three solid
times in my seven years
it could have been massively damaging to
the world where americans would have
been killed innocent americans would
have been killed there's a very clear
example of that there's a place where we
would probably be
10 to 15 years
behind where we are right now in terms
of the global economic situation between
china russia and the united states had
had one of our operations not happened
um
and then there was another one that was
in africa where it would have been like
innocent non-american lives but allied
lives western lives now
uh british citizens canadian citizens a
mix just group that was targeted by a
fringe extremist group in africa so we
have those victories we celebrate those
victories we love those victories we
don't talk about those victories i guess
my biggest thing becomes if if there's a
bigger push to go private then go public
because
the challenge becomes there is zero
competition for cia you have a monopoly
there's zero competition for fbi you
have a monopoly that is not good there's
a reason why we have monopoly laws when
a t went through it microsoft went to
went through it you know even facebook
right now is going through hey we got to
kind of break it apart your two this
your two that okay i actually understand
some of those conversations but
why have monopoly loss for free
enterprise and not have monopoly laws
for government agencies i think we need
monopoly laws for government agencies
how does a patent differ from
a monopoly
patent gives you a timeline you don't
have it forever correct okay right
monopolies don't last for either forever
either they they incentivize people to
create competition and monopolies are
intentionally
attacked by the federal government where
patents are protected by the federal
government sure so what i'm saying is
that there's a place for everything
there's a place for patents there's a
place for monopoly there's a place for
secret intelligence services there's a
place for one-sided advantage absolutely
but there should be checks and balances
there are checks and balances in our in
our private intelligence world and our
secret intelligence world publicly and
privately
but what we're also finding is that
there's vulnerabilities that nobody
talks about the vast majority of
espionage cases right now are coming
from private intelligence
they're coming from chinese russian
iranian
penetrations through the private
intelligence network into a mainstream
building we just there was just two a
husband and wife couple i don't know if
you want to look it up husband and wife
couple that were working that were
teachers
in
i don't know where it was somewhere in
the northeast but they were caught
spying giving nuclear secrets about
american submarine technology to an
unnamed foreign service they were just
arrested because they were contracted
the husband was contracted as a as an
engineer to go
to go work with the navy and now
because of that in maryland thank you
very much
this just happened nobody knows this
happened this doesn't make headlines
this is the kind of stuff where where
we're doing the right thing and nobody
even knows it's happening this happens
all the time unpack the story so what
happened here maryland husband and wife
arrested a nuclear submarine spy case
the couple are accused of selling
nuclear secrets including a sd card
concealed in a peanut butter sandwich
this is classic human intelligence
espionage i would i would suspect that
this that the unnamed service that
they're talking about here is the
chinese because this fits a chinese
model of collecting military secrets on
american technology
right down to the fact that they were
doing dead drops in maryland in food
but let's let's break that down a little
bit because i think you could make the
case that even though it may be a
private institution it's still
technically controlled by the ccp right
and i think
it's because it's tied to the chinese
government i think you could make the
same case for russia and i i don't
disagree with pat on the idea that we
should privatize
uh uh intelligence agencies but i think
you mentioned raytheon so like how do we
keep if we do go that route how do we
keep from raytheon making up false
intelligence to sell weapons right or
like going down that path to where
they're they're no longer focused on the
actual intelligence they're focused on
the bottom line of the profit well
that's one of the reasons that you want
to have a national intelligence
organization because one of the ways
that you differentiate information from
intelligence is through a process called
vetting information can be single source
one time you hear it you can't find it
anywhere else vetting means you have to
find the same piece of information in
multiple different unrelated sources
right so the difference between
information intelligence is specific but
what i'm saying here is this penetration
these secrets were lost because of the
privatization of of intelligence had
this been a naval engineer working only
within the navy it would have been
harder
for a foreign intelligence service to
recruit them and get them to provide
secrets but because this person was a
civilian working for a private
organization contracted by the navy it
was easier so you're saying there's more
risk to being privatized there's more
risk to being privatized just like
there's more risk to any company hiring
anybody like how do you know if you work
in the number one company in
pharmaceuticals that the number two
company in pharmaceuticals doesn't
recruit your top sales so so let me tell
you this i fully fully agree between
what you're saying fully agree with what
you're saying however there's a big
however
so
there there is risk to both sides it's
which risk you want more so which of the
two
has more of a risk to bully
the american people i trust the market
i'm with you okay so trust the market
here's where i'm going with that see the
market cannot bully the american people
they're gonna eventually get caught but
the government can bully american people
that's exactly what they're doing today
they're bullying american people and so
although
you're right we're a person on the free
market side because they're getting paid
for the work that they're doing
you know they may be like well if you
give me 500 000 i'll give you the
information if you give me a million
dollars but we know a lot of government
agency people have done that as well and
you know sold their soul to i can tell
you stories there's plenty of articles
of different names you know them i know
them we've read about them so
but
my my bigger concern is free enterprise
cannot take my freedoms away
but uh the government can't take my
freedoms away and bully me and uh
a lot of times what they do is they use
you know like andrew tate this guy never
met him never talked to him we're
probably gonna do podcasts together
eventually but he said some stuff i
agree with and i love the fact that he's
pushing the envelope all of a sudden hey
let's silence this guy okay why because
uh he's got a case going on with uh
women and all this other stuff okay
there is criminal activities that you
have to you know be held accountable for
and then there's banning because he's
saying some stuff you disagree with
on the criminal side if i break the law
yes i have to go to court and if i'm
doing time i'm doing time big difference
i don't know what he's done if he's done
crime hey that's the level of
accountability but banning somebody for
things you disagree with o.j simpson is
on twitter you did the khamenei is on
twitter
putin who just killed a bunch of people
he's on twitter he ain't banned how come
they're not banned you're afraid of what
this guy is going to be doing so that's
the part where i wonder if government
gets involved and saying that guy's been
a little too loud shut this guy up and
i free market can bully by saying we
don't want your customer it's simple
facebook can say that twitter can say
that instagram can't say that
but are they saying it because they're
saying i like this whole story going
into facebook where
you know he sits with uh rogan uh uh uh
yeah zuck sits with rogan and they go
through a bunch of different stories
and uh
you know here's a story from fox
business fbi response to zuckerberg's
claim on rogue in that facebook limited
hunter biden story
uh after agency's warning an appearance
by mark zuckerberg on joe rogan podcast
last week still controversy after
medacio admitted that facebook limited
the bombshell hunter biden laptop story
ahead of the 2020 election because the
fbi had warned about
russian propaganda after the release of
the episode on thursday the fbi said it
routinely notifies u.s private sector
entities including social media
providers of potential threat
information so that they can decide how
to better defend against threats the
agency said it has provided companies
with foreign threat indicators to help
them protect their platforms and
customers from abuse by foreign malign
influencer influence actors okay
you read this
i can take this in a couple different
ways one way i take this is zuck did
this intentionally
because he's like i'm so sick of you
guys targeting me leave me alone okay
i have two customers the left to right i
have to kind of deal with both of you
guys and both of you guys hate the other
side i get it
but let me do my job so maybe he said
this publicly
intentionally to get on the fbi's uh
skin and kind of have them be exposed a
little bit maybe 10 percent i believe it
was intentional
did he do it accidentally he's too smart
to do it accidentally like was joe
really cornering him and pressuring him
you better tell me or else and you know
here's one no it's just a basic
conversation where it came out
could it be accidental but when somebody
says something like this
this this just keeps hurting more and
more and more so the fbi bullied the
american people through cornering a free
enterprise company that made them
silence because they didn't have the
intel that the fbi claimed they had and
they couldn't verify it through private
agency that's a competitor to fbi that
they had to kind of take that position
and because of that we have the greatest
motivational speaker of all time as our
president joe biden right so it's kind
of like a very weird situation that
takes place here
yeah so what you're i think that there's
a couple things that we want to keep in
mind we want to keep in mind the context
of the situation so if you recall 2016.
first of all let's be let's be very
honest with each other
russian meddling in the u.s elections
did not start in 2016.
every election cycle ever has had people
trying to meddle in the election what
happened is that in 2016 social media
got caught
that's what happened in 16. before then
we could all kind of pretend it wasn't
there it's like the it's like that uncle
in our family that we don't want to talk
about because they're kind of maybe
they're a criminal or maybe they went to
jail or who knows what they did but we
don't really
we don't want to we don't want to be the
one who calls the police and turns the
uncle in but we also don't want to be
the person who admits that we know the
uncle or the uncle's in our family right
that's exactly what happens with
espionage almost all the time people
don't want to admit that it's there but
it's happening all the time it's that
ugly wart on your butt you don't want
anybody to know about right what
happened in 16 is everybody saw the ward
espionage became a household word
influence campaigns covert influence
became household conversation in 2020
everyone was expecting it to happen
again trump was back back in the race
russia was still involved all the 16
investigations came to fruition in 18
and you had cia basically telling us
that they couldn't trust the president
and the president saying that he didn't
trust cia and it was a disaster it was a
total mess
the social media companies did not want
to get stuck in the middle of being
accused in the future of being willing
voices for propaganda from russian
meddling or chinese meddling or iranian
meddling all of which happens saudi
meddling happens right nobody wants to
nobody wants to be on the x for that so
the more cautious approach is to just
shut it down if fbi calls you and says
hey this is russian meddling we think
this is russian meddling what does what
does zuck have to lose
by being overly cautious and just doing
what they tell him to do to a certain
extent you're right he's saying just
leave me alone guys let me do what i do
i'm not a political mouthpiece i'm just
a social media channel
but i'm also a business owner and the
practical solution here is if the fbi
tells me that i might be being abused by
the russians i don't want the russians
to abuse my platform so i'm just going
to shut it down
two years later we have the benefit of
time now now we can look back and look
at all the information he had limited
information in a short period of time i
actually am really proud of zuckerberg
for saying it publicly like hey i agree
i had to shut it down guys
it doesn't mean that fbi is bullying me
it means i took the more conservative
decision and maybe that was the wrong
decision but by the way that's publicly
standing up to fbi correct and then
that's he had we all as american
citizens we have the right to stand up
to our own government that's what the
first amendment promises us he's already
screwed up by the way like he you know
he screwed he screwed up the election
because him and dorsey both of them took
the fear position and it was so sudden
was they
okay
strategically can we all agree that that
story was
held till the week prior to the election
because that's the bond that we're going
to drop to flip the voting at the last
minute we all know
that would have been intentional it's
not like they just got the story last
minute if i'm a skeptic i'm assuming new
york post had that story for a while
and they were timing on when to drop it
that's my skepticism i may be wrong
so
and in politics stories matter on
timing matters on when they drop it so
he
essentially affected the election so
dorsey essentially affected the election
the fact that he's saying that now
i think he's more doing this to say
don't come bothering me for 2024.
i i don't disagree with you so i will i
will say that i don't necessarily agree
that the washington
uh the wall street journal washington
times whoever broke the story
i'm not saying that they dropped the
story when they dropped it specifically
to change the direction of the election
they dropped it at a very intentional
time most likely to get maximum readers
maximum views of their advertisement
maximum you know
press coverage and secondary by like
viral coverage not to sway an election
but what i will also say is that there's
only one person or not one person
there's one entity that has the
responsibility for the way the elections
turned out and that's the american
people
if you stood in line and you voted you
own the vote that you cast that day
zuckerberg did not change the course of
the election
did he have a tool that could have been
used to sway it sure but ultimately
somebody went and stood in line cast a
vote and that's the person who owns the
responsibility for the outcome right now
that's the person who owns the
responsibility for every single outcome
that's why you have to vote that's why
you have the right to vote we just have
to understand especially if you look at
2020 2020 was a freakish year a hard
time processing that i have a very hard
time processing that so
you're telling me
the person who voted has the ultimate
responsibility for the results for the
vote they cast for the vote they cast i
understand but
the journalists have a responsibility
for digging up and getting the
information
to the people so they can read it before
voting to be as educated as possible
journalists and these virtual
governments such as facebook twitter
youtube have to permit that information
to be released to the public so they can
make the most educated vote which they
prevent it from happening so you can't i
have a hard time saying in this case
that it's the voters responsibility on
the way they voted no they did not have
access to the entire information this
article says 79 say truthful coverage of
hunter biden's laptop would have changed
the 2020 election and the numbers they
gave his majority in both parties 89 of
republicans which is fine that makes i'm
surprised it's not 99 republicans but 89
percent of republicans
61
of democrats
said they believe the laptop is real
along with 74
of independents so if the difference
between it coming out a week versus a
week after that that's a very big
difference right let me show you a quick
spy tool sure right so um what's what's
our i'm sorry
tyler do me a favor go to this article
and then look up the specific survey i
did this after i saw this article i want
to show you exactly how to spy new
jersey i looked at it yeah i saw that
yes the first thing i did this is what
new york post did you see the population
that they tested 1 000 uh uh 226 1226
you know what a statistical relevant
population is what's that three thousand
okay so this is not a statistical and
not a statistically relevant
representation of a survey result they
could essentially have called 1022
old republicans in a single district to
ask them this question and get this
result surveys are no to polls are no i
trust two polls i trust two polls is
this one of them no that's not one of
them so this is this is what i'm saying
about what i tell you yesterday by the
way what i said to you yesterday when i
said look up the pole who's the buyer
uh i said i tell you which two polls
i'll pay attention to you or uh uh
gallop those two i'll pay attention to
them i'm not going past
uh direct everything else i'll like
temple
yep no i totally get it i fully get it
so these guys when i looked at this
that's when i was like well they can
shape their pace forget about these guys
just just the four of us talking right
now and whoever else that's watching
this right
you mean to tell me the story
not being released didn't impact the
story did so here's i want to make sure
that we're aligning responsibility in
the right place please zuckerberg does
not zuckerberg runs a business he does
not run a second government a federal a
commercial government shadow government
he runs a business
the journalists have a journalistic
responsibility to report the facts amen
one thousand percent true journalism
is dying journalism some people say is
fully dead and the journalists who write
for most of these mainstream news
sources hate the way that the editors
handle their journalistic
responsibilities because the editor does
not have a journalistic responsibility
like the journalist does
so they're forced to produce at a
certain speed before they can do what's
needed to meet journalistic requirements
and then information is controlled by a
business that wants to spend its time
being you know protective of its own
long-term business interests i'm sure
you get that
and then what's left is the human being
the person the american on the other
side is scrolling through facebook only
reading what they see
and we have given that person that
american has got the permission now to
think that it's okay to get your news
from facebook it's not okay to get your
news from facebook it's not okay to get
your news from just one source of
anything but
what do you mean it's not okay to get
your news from facebook though facebook
isn't a platform where i get my news
from because they write it facebook is
where stories go viral correct twitter
is where stories go viral correct for
you to prevent a very damaging story to
not go viral for the public to know
before they vote knowing this is a very
corrupt
situation here
you're essentially manipulating the
election and then the world paid a price
for it because if the election was a
possibly in a different way say somebody
else becomes president
russia probably doesn't attack ukraine
lives could have been saved there we
probably don't lose 83 billion dollars
of equipment in afghanistan because that
would have been handled in a different
way
and you know economy would probably be
in a slightly different place inflation
would be in a different place many
things would be in a different place
if it wasn't for the and the american
people today are paying a price for it
yesterday poll came out i don't know if
you saw the poll or not on who they're
saying the leading candidate is
for presidency did you see that or not
yeah it's a story by fox okay so story
came out what page is that on page seven
so you've seen this i'll read it to you
so page seven this is yesterday
uh uh uh uh is it paid seven
do you know which one i'm looking at uh
tyler or yeah bottom of six are you
talking about bernie sanders no it's not
that one it's another one where it says
bernie sanders is the leading candidate
yeah leading polls
uh yeah it's page six is it page six
yeah okay so if i go to the hill story
high school so sanders
sanders has highest favorability among
possible 2024 contender poll this is a
hill story this is not a fox story or
cnn sanders clocked in with the highest
favorability rating amongst the list of
23 potential 2024 candidate con
presidential contenders according to a
new usa today poll
46 of respondents say they had at least
a somewhat favorable view
towards sanders while 41 said they had
an unfavorable opinion president biden
had the second highest at rating of 43
percent
although his unfavorability was uh
notably higher than sanders at 52
and then you know trump clocked in with
the same rating as biden so again polls
usa today we know which side they're
going to lean of course they're going to
want a sanders you know because it's
going to be sample size yeah they're
going to want to be able to use that
part as well but at the same time i
think when you're saying facebook
twitter these guys don't have
responsibility i think they have a
responsibility of allowing the message
to be released the populace what the
populace you and i the citizens the
voters have a responsibility for
is not to jump to conclusion is to do
our own due diligence before voting
but that the responsibility is for them
so releasing of the information is on
facebook
they got to release that part the
information is out there regardless of
whether it's on facebook i could just
get it from a different news source i
know bro but i can post the same video
clip
on instagram on facebook on twitter on
youtube on tick tock and all of a sudden
one of them like for example tick tock
i'll tell you perfect situation if you
go back look at my tick tock account
i was posting videos and i was getting
100 views 600 000 views 100 000 views
eight hundred thousand five million
views two point one million is 1.8
million views i post two clips about
china
find the clip after it's been 50 videos
since that clip find the clip after that
if any one of them have ever done 10 000
views
i'm like okay content is content one of
the clips posted by somebody else got
six million views of the same thing i
said on a smaller platform posted it but
i put it on mine it got 11 000 views
so virality is about the gods of viral
to allow an article to go viral
today when an article is going viral
social media they know when the
trigger's back in uh oh look at this
this thing's going viral what is that
okay let it go uh-oh this thing's going
viral oh yeah let it go oh this thing's
going right shut it down shut it down
shut it down shut it down shut it
goes like this i've seen videos on on
november 22nd
five years ago i did an interview with
jim jenkins and jim jenkins was one of
the four guys that held john f kennedy's
brain he was in the autopsy room he
stayed quiet for 50 years christian man
quiet man never wanted to talk to
anybody who was afraid because they told
him if you say anything we're going to
take the navy money away from you so
this guy doesn't want to talk finally he
says i want to talk about it but he
comes in if you ever see the interview
he was so nervous
we put it out on november 22nd which is
the assassination day the video goes
like this boom
boom
boom
then suddenly it went like this right
that doesn't happen what platform
youtube that doesn't happen it went like
this
and then it stayed like this okay
so what does that mean wait a minute
wait a minute wait a minute hold this
thing back
a person on the back and when i look at
my creative studios i can see i've never
in the history of my 1800 videos i've
ever seen a video do that
why is this happening sometimes these
types of things happen
because these platforms have the ability
to prevent
these types of toxins to become
converted so that's my only concern with
facebook and i think i want to be able
to be an optimist and i think
what zuck is trying to say is guys next
time we're on fbi we're telling the
story and we're not getting in the way i
think that's what he's saying now
whether he'll follow through with that
or not we have no idea yeah there's
there's an interesting relationship
between national security and big
business in the united states biden's
laptop is a hunter biden's laptop is an
excellent example the make and model of
that laptop is an apple
how did they get onto an apple without
the user
how did they do that you shouldn't be
allowed to do that you know what fbi has
long had a contentious relationship with
apple big time apple won't let them on
to iphone san bernardino yeah the san
bernardino
exactly right how the hell did they get
on how do they get on this apple what's
your skepticism my point here is you can
see that apple does not protect your
privacy like they promise that they do
they choose which platform which device
to let who on when
right in this case they let somebody
onto this guy's apple
and in other cases they won't let fbi
get onto an apple iphone that belongs to
a saudi pilot who kills a bunch of
people in pensacola
so there's a relationship between the
government and apple
and apple chooses when to share and when
not to share so this is this this
relationship that you're talking about
with zuckerberg yeah it happens in
social media it happens in all big
government all big organizations
all big companies in the united states
because companies
they get big enough they have a
responsibility to contribute to national
security some play nicely others play
inconsistently others don't play well at
all
so what you're seeing is every company
has to learn it has to mature and evolve
its own position on how am i going to be
how am i going to plug myself in to this
national security context i want to say
we have the guy here who uh uh he had
the laptop john paul mackey we had him
here six weeks ago seven weeks ago
and
i want to say when hunter brings it in
the password to get into the computer
was given i wanna i wanna assume it was
given because he let him log on well he
was working on it that's what i'm saying
so i want to assume i don't think it was
apple
uh uh i think the government can't stand
apple because they don't give the
information that they do because tim
cook uh a is very interesting guy by the
way tim cook is a very very interesting
guy on how he
uh uh works uh with
the government how he works with
different presidents and who he is first
gay pro ceo of a fortune 500 company to
come out and but at the same time he
had a good relationship with trump and
he had a good relationship with you know
very interesting way how he is but uh i
don't know i won't be if it's true it's
true maybe apple gave him the
information but from what i know from
the guy that was here seven weeks ago i
thought he got the password to log into
the system but you you don't have an
apple phone you're not a fan of apple
correct correct all right you're a droid
are you a droid person i use android
mainly because it's the other option
right there's only like two major
options that are out there there's other
options when you get to super high
levels and that's just a personal
preference or there's a moral political
it's because no reason yeah it's because
of care if people are killing if
terrorists are killing americans
what kind what business stance do you
have as an american company to not let
to not help
the fbi solve that case you don't have
to help them solve every case but how
the hell are you choosing to not protect
we can't investigate a saudi arabian
phone we can't investigate a network of
phones that belong to known terrorists
why can't we investigate those phones
right
you obviously have a way to get into the
phone because you guarantee service to
all of your clients so you already have
a back door we don't need to know the
code to the back door but but at what
point do you decide when you're
responsible for the security of
americans and when do you decide that
you're not responsible for security but
by the way you know we just made me
think about you you just made me think
about so how many how many employees
does apple have 400 000 i don't know
what the number it's a massive number
you mean to tell me none of those guys
on the inside who can't stand a
president on either side
won't
somehow release the password to the
government in a way that nobody will
find out i'm sure they could
i'm sure they could
so there's always leaks yeah how many
it's the wart on our butt that we were
just talking about right thirty seven
thousand employees yes well it's it's
like four hundred thousand yeah four
hundred thousand employees yeah
it makes you it makes you kind of think
about the fact that whistleblowers on
the
you're seeing what the project veritas
is doing i have to say you know i'm
curious to know what you say how does a
cia or fbi how do they look at a project
veritas what do they think about an
organization like that so i am not
familiar with project verification okay
you're not familiar with the motif
what is it you've never heard of james
o'keefe
the name is not ringing in a bell form
really yeah okay you i'm surprised
because that guy is
well you may want to look him up if you
just look him up you'll see because
project veritas is everywhere with what
he's got going on okay so let's talk
about the mar-a-lago rate and what
happened there okay
so
at this point of the game you know the
story the people know the story it's
gone back and forth now they're saying
hey former fbi official says russian
chinese and iranian spies could have
tried to infiltrate trump's mar-a-lago
residence this is an insider story which
i believe is
said by peter strzok the same guy was
talking to you about earlier
uh who was once the deputy director of
fbi's counterintelligence division said
that it is likely that foreign agents
from russia china tried to infiltrate
former trump's former president trump's
mar-a-lago residents considering the top
secret documents that were being kept
there strzok was fired from the agency
for sending anti-trump texts
on his work phone absolutely the
russians but not the russians alone any
contempt foreign intelligence services
whether that's uh those belonging to
china those belonging to iran to cuba
certainly including russia are all were
very inter were interested and are
interested in gaining access to
mar-a-lago he said
especially concerning the lack of any
sort of control of memorization
uh memorialization of who had access to
mar-a-lago at any given time so when you
hear something like that and what
happened with mar-a-lago first of all
just the position that they took where
you know biden says oh we had no clue
about it this is not something we knew
about it you know and then garland is
the only one i know nothing about it
it's not my project somebody else's yeah
okay there is eight billion people in
the world there's only one other guy
that's a former president
if somebody raids that guy who was your
inanimate you know he's your enemy he's
the guy that you don't want to go up
against you knew nothing about it none
of that was disclosed to you and then
when they give the affidavit you saw
what came out with all the black bars
and you know nothing is we wanted to be
disclosed
for someone like you who's in the world
what how are you processing what
happened to you with mar-a-lago so trump
has been a target of investigations
since the time he was running for
president in 2016. this is just the next
this is a predictable breadcrumb in that
long-term trail right do i there's a
there's a
um a tool that we use at the agency
called harem's razor and harem's razor
tells us to never subscribe to
conspiracy
what can be explained through
incompetence
so never subscribe to conspiracy what
can be explained through incompetence so
do i believe that biden knew that this
was going to happen
probably not
he maybe it was on a list somewhere that
got buried on the bottom of his 10-page
list and he just never got to it maybe
he was supposed to be briefed and
someone didn't brief him maybe the
department of justice which falls under
the judicial branch of government
actually decided not to tell him because
he is the executive branch of government
and we have three different branches
that don't have to communicate
everything to each other so who knows
how it turned out
but i don't see conspiracy in this what
i see in this is a continuation of the
same sort of hunting behavior to find
enough evidence to bring some kind of
criminal prosecution against trump that
sticks
and it's the same thing that we did for
a long time against hillary clinton so
this is just unfortunately this is the
this is the
the world of politics that americans are
going to live in for a while as we try
to mix executive branch and judicial
branch and keep trying to hunt down
politicians and business people acting
like businessmen and politicians
how much is this is political
incentivization versus actual all right
let's figure out the truth here in your
opinion i think a lot of it is political
um i don't think the truth is something
that that the government is particularly
interested in when it comes to trump
they either know the truth
to a high enough probability that
that they can make their decisions
moving forward or they don't know the
truth but they also can't just ignore it
to just ignore it would mean to
basically let go of all of the time and
all of the money and all of the effort
that they've put into it so far and
let's not forget trump is still an
extremely powerful player in republican
politics extremely powerful player
whether he runs for president or not
what he says about a candidate
transforms that candidate's
opportunities
you brought up hillary clinton and i
assume you're talking about the
the parallel between her email server
and top security information and this
exact same scenario with trump what's
the parallel you're seeing there people
hunt people try to hunt down some sort
of judicial criminal action to to
either eradicate or neutralize the
threat of that politician it's just i
mean whether we the stuff that we saw in
2016 on just the democratic side was
horrible we saw the clinton campaign we
saw the democratic national convention
undermine sanders intentionally when he
was running against clinton
like that that is manipulation of
politics all day long the idea that the
voter gets the ultimate say yes that's
true but then you also have things like
in 2020 when instagram decided to start
telling everybody as soon as you log
into instagram as soon as you opened up
the app register to vote click here to
register to vote it was pushing
registrations to vote of the audience
that that they knew was on instagram
which is a certain age demographic a
certain socioeconomic demographic et
cetera et cetera et cetera which i mean
that was common that's this is the world
that we're living in now as everybody
starts to get so heavily involved in
politics
and we start seeing conspiracy
everywhere when what we really need to
be accepting is like this is america's
adolescence we're not a mature country
we're just over 200 years old we're not
mature china's 4 000 years old
right we're we're coming into our
adolescence growing pains and hair in
new parts of our body that we never saw
before remember how terrible that felt
when you couldn't wear sweatpants to
school anymore that's a horrible feeling
for a dude that's where we are right now
when we've got like 50 to 100 years of
adolescence coming up and this is the
kind of garbage we're gonna have to deal
with
yeah i have i i and by the way i
understand what you're saying on on the
truth um
conspiracies
um
have a very hard time believing that the
president didn't know they were going to
be doing this a very very hard time
believing
you're again
for example like lebron james
who are the people
that he's gonna know everything that's
going on with those people
michael jordan's probably one of them
because he's trying to pass up michael
jordan okay
like he probably sees everything that's
going on with michael okay all right
barack obama
who was he seeing that's you know what's
going on with anything with them he
probably followed everything that was
going on with the clintons because you
know behind closed doors they're
apparently big competitors and he was
probably following everything was going
on with trump even when he gave that one
speech from stage you know and he did
the tweet and you know trump said this
about you on jimmy fallon or camino says
at least
i will go down as being the president
you know you won't be a president to
trump because yeah so you know you know
hey elections have consequences and
obama looks to the left he's right you
know so i have a hard time believing in
the game of competition
that you don't know that they're doing
this or i didn't know this was going on
and when you say you don't know what's
going on do you know how pathetic you
look as a leader
wait let me get this straight you did
not do that that's going on yeah man
what a kind of a leader are you that you
don't know this kind of stuff is going
on if you don't know what's going on
with him maybe you shouldn't be in
office because a person that should know
what's
in office should have known that this is
going on
yeah it's it's
both ways no matter what direction you
say i didn't know i did know it's it
doesn't look good for anybody no i agree
i agree with that it doesn't look good
for anybody there's a you keep there's a
word that you uh that you used quite a
bit in that explanation right the word
was probably
and the core the core word in probably
is probable the root word is probable
probable refers to probability
so when so what the word probably
actually means is there is a high
probability that such and such is true
yeah i absolutely agree with you there
is a probability
that biden knew
i just don't know that it's a high
probability 51 versus 49
i think there's a very high probability
someone tried to communicate it to him
but i don't know that there's a higher
probability he actually knew on all the
things on that dude's list
the lowest presidential approval ratings
in history
in history the lowest presidential
approval ratings ever
that dude's got a whole lot of crap on
his plate and maybe the mar-a-lago raid
didn't make the top of his sheet that
day
all right i mean i've seen the
presidential daily brief the pdb that
they get every day they don't get
through the pdb every day
every they can't it's like 100 pages
every single day right about all the
biggest threats facing america
the mar-a-lago rate is not a threat to
america
right so even if it was in there
buried under iran and they're posturing
about nuclear weapons and north korea
launching a weapon and what's gonna
happen in china right now and what's
russia doing in ukraine and what's syria
looking like right now and what's gonna
happen in yemen what's gonna happen in
in libya like think about the headache
the president has every day it's one of
the reasons why no matter how you feel
about trump you got to respect the fact
that he sat in that seat for four years
that's everybody who takes that
presidential seat
that is a massive they age look at what
happened to obama look at what happened
to bush
they age so fast because that is a that
is a [ __ ] seat to sit in
so going back to
when you were an agent seven years and
you're in it and you're seeing what's
going on
and both your perspective and your
wife's perspective so when you're laying
in bed and you guys are both talking to
each other and you guys are still
married to each other today so even
after you get out eight years later you
guys still chose to be married because
it's kind of tough when you get out life
is like a very different life so
um
okay
so
when you went in
where did you
did any area of trust go higher you're
like oh man i used to have no respect
for those i got a lot of respect for
what those guys are doing you should go
in and say i never thought about those
guys damn those guys are dangerous after
seven years of being in
and then you went and you said oh those
are the guys that were studying those
guys are a hundred times more scary to
the world
than the is even selling
and then the media yeah i used to really
trust the media used to say dude i don't
trust [ __ ] to say or i used to not trust
what the media is actually trust what
they have to say
what were some of the things where you
flipped where what you saw pre and now
you're on the inside what flipped on you
the biggest flip was media the she the
biggest flip out there was news i when i
started seeing what real intelligence
looks like
and how real intelligence is collected
how information is vetted and processed
and synthesized and turned into
something useful and then i would read
the news
i realize that the news is garbage like
the even the best news sources out there
the most centrist the most
highly rated news sources out there they
are still a far cry from what they were
in the 1950s when journalism was alive
when there were still laws in place that
forced you to have fair and balanced
news right now news news organizations
focus on feeding their audience base
that's what they do then if they get too
far off of their audience base then they
start to see a decrease in ratings and a
decrease in ad revenue and that they
can't have that especially not now that
people don't buy newspapers
so that was a massive flip for me some
of the other flips were the french
i went i was a military officer
you you were you were in the military
nobody says good things about the french
in the military we make fun of them all
the time right this is how the french go
to war right we make fun of them all the
time
you get into the intelligence service
the dgse is scary
they are so well funded they are so
technically adept they are hunting down
corporate and economic espionage secrets
from us and we don't even know they're
there they are super powerful had no
idea that was happening no idea at all
and then you know mossad has a
reputation mossad is actually when you
deal with them in real life they're
pretty reasonable people they just have
the authority to do some crazy [ __ ]
compared to what we do in the united
states but generally speaking like you
sit down you have a beer with them like
you were saying about the trifecta right
you're justin timberlake they can dance
they can act they can sing right
you sit down with with a massage officer
and you're like you seem like a fair and
reasonable person who is also protected
by law
like unable to just kill somebody on the
spot i have to ask five levels up
whether or not i'm allowed to slap
somebody in the in the belly when
they're being interrogated in guantanamo
bay you know what i mean it's and
there's just so there's all sorts of
different things like that then i also
started to learn how scary terrorists
actually were
um you know the world knew about al
qaeda al qaeda by the time that al qaeda
was a mainstream thing al qaeda wasn't
actually that scary they did they were
well funded they had organization and
bureaucracy and reach but bureaucracy
slows you down
isis was terrifying isis is still in a
phase where it's recruiting what's known
as lone wolf terrorists lone wolves are
basically people they radicalize and
encourage to act and operate
independently and alone
so then there is no communication
channel anywhere of anybody saying hey
i'm going to hit this target this way
what do you think if there's no
communication there's no way to collect
intelligence these lone wolves can just
go out and do whatever they think
they're going to do and they've got the
permission of the organization and they
have you know the praise of the
caliphate behind them
that's scary stuff exactly what happened
with salman rushdie was a lone wolf and
his mother just disowned him did you see
what she said about him he just said
she's i can no longer support him being
my son
it's nuts that's that that world is a
terrifying world that the average
american has no idea let me ask you
because pat framed the question with
your perspective what has shifted you've
been pretty vocal about um
perception versus perspective right
getting out of your own shoes and
looking to the eyes of others he also
framed it with um you know what you said
the media and you've been pretty vocal
about the perception perspective we also
talked about your wife how
when she kind of got red pilled into the
real world how she's went from being a
progressive liberal to being more
centered same thing with you i i assume
is right correct yeah yeah i mean you
don't if you're a super conservative
you're not trying to go to africa to
like save children right you're trying
to build a business or do something that
that boosts the economy in some way
shape or form so i we were both moved
very very very far to independent center
once we started realizing
not necessarily that there was like a
liberal narrative and it really
frustrates me when i hear people go off
the deep end about all these liberal
conspiracies and these liberal
narratives that the truth is that
liberals are just that that whole media
is feeding its own base and it's feeding
a base of people who don't make a lot of
money who don't have a lot of education
who who are struggling to set themselves
up financially so they want to believe
that someone else should take care of
them and they want to believe that
someone else should help them and they
want to believe that they that a larger
big brother government should be on
their side but what ends up happening
across the board time and time again is
your 27 year old liberal becomes a 32
year old parent with a career or a
business and then their perspective
shifts because now they got to protect
what they have they got to protect their
family they got to take care of their
people they've got to make sure that the
future because now there's a child
you've got to protect your child but you
also need a military to protect your
child so you know what if i have to pick
between who lives and who dies
my child lives somebody else dies so
you're like a living breathing case same
with your wife of you know the the
famous phrase if you're
young and you're not a liberal you have
no heart and if you're older and you're
you're not a conservative you have no
brain is that kind of what your the
process you went through yeah it's like
i mean those every all of these idioms
and all of these uh all of these uh
stereotypes right they they happen for a
reason they happen because a normalized
statistically relevant number of people
start to follow in these certain trends
it doesn't mean it's right for everyone
but it's right for a majority of people
so
you know as a registered independent
i've been a voter republican i've owed a
democrat i'm a registered independent
now for i don't know 11 years or 12
years something like that
and rogan you see he was a libertarian
he's voted he voted for george jorgensen
which
uh yeah we was voting for bernie a few
which we had joe jorgensen on here
i i
i don't know if she'll ever come back i
i don't know if i don't know
i asked her back she was upset she
didn't want to come back on but
you put a fork in her but but the point
the point being is the following
he says with aaron rodgers he sits there
and he says well so what do we do and he
says vote republican aaron starts
laughing what did you think when rogan
is a guy that
you would have never thought rogan's
gonna say vote republican this guy
pushed to legalize marijuana this guy
pushed to
you know talking about certain things
that there's nothing about it would be
republican but a guy like him is now
saying voting republican what was your
reaction when you saw that so when i saw
when i saw what rogan said i was it was
very similar to what i had when i saw
what zuckerberg did i was like good for
you joe like that's
like speak your heart if you're not if
you've got a voice you've got an awesome
voice man if you've got a voice speak
your heart if you're speaking to
anything else you're kind of wasting
your voice right joe spoke with his
voice zuck spoke with his voice i think
that's really good stuff it's important
to remember that human beings
are not
left or right
human beings are all a mix of both
we just we want what we want that we we
are motivated by the things that are
important and motivate us
so you don't you're not all red you're
not all blue there's always a bell curve
so at the fat end of the bell curve
people are close to center people
believe in some things and believe in
other things but unfortunately media
doesn't give you a chance to be
supportive of both
media forces you to choose one or the
other and then they feed you lines from
one or the other and they move you
closer and closer to the outside of the
bell curve until you choose to just stop
reading the news or you choose to just
stop watching tv or you choose to sit
around and drink beer and watch sports
games and [ __ ] about the news all day
right
but media's in the business of forcing
you to one side of the other human
beings
are not like that right i believe a
woman should have the choice to take
care of her own body i do believe in the
sanctity of life but a woman should have
the choice to take care of her own body
but the government does not need to tax
me at 40
i can spend my money wisely on my own i
don't need them to police my money i
don't need them to police
like what i'm doing in my bedroom i
don't need the government to police how
i raise my children or whether they're
homeschooled or private schooled or
whether i'm dissatisfied with the public
school right we have we're all a mix
of of all sorts of different positions
and we are all getting frustrated by
being forced to pick one side or the
other should the government have access
to know if you have that word on your
butt that's the question
i think they're curious to know knowing
the way they are like if maybe you
should stop mooning people so they want
to find out you know obviously that's an
analogy are there any news sources that
you legitimately trust like you're
saying you know you don't trust the
media that was like your biggest
discrepancy with what today like what
outlets you say okay because pat said
that he
if when it comes to polls he said pew
and what was the other one rasmussen
gallop gallup he trusts that all right
they're not 100 accurate but with the
level of certainty probability like you
termed the use
what what media outlets do you trust so
i don't i don't trust any of them fully
i trust at best i trust about 85
the way that i handle the news is i will
read competing news sources on the same
coverage on purpose and see where they
overlap right give us an example so the
wall street journal so the economist
okay the economist is a great example
we've got two minutes just so you know
the economy is a great example cnn is a
great example um fox news is not such a
great example yahoo news is actually a
decent usa today is actually a decent
example um al jazeera is a decent
example um bbc is a decent example these
are all places that i'm like 80 85
percent even though they they
consistently what did you say about
something consistently lean one side i
don't look at msnbc about cnn cnn's on
my list only because they were very
consistently left
and when i started seeing them trash
talking biden about nine months ago i
was like there's a change in cnn right
they still go with popular opinion
they're still just trying to sell ad
space right but when it comes to who's
who's gonna get my time i'll look at
them i'll cross-reference them i'll see
what's the same i'll see what's
different i'll believe what's the same
and i'll challenge what's different
interesting okay this was great uh by
the way if you enjoyed this as much as i
did give it a thumbs up and subscribe to
the channel and if you want to hear more
um
content of andy andy has a youtube
channel which i want us to put that
below in the chat box
as well as description title if you can
put that down there so people can go
subscribe to his channel and find more
content of him and make sure to check
out everyday spy yeah everyday spy.com
is my homepage and that's where i teach
all of this stuff to anybody who's
willing to learn everydayspy.com every
day sick domain
seriously
by the way if it wasn't for time no joke
i would have gone two more hours because
i have so many questions but i have an
11 o'clock zoom uh folks we're going to
do a pocket it was not scheduled this
week we have the vault conference for
the entire week which we got a couple
thousand people coming in
uh and we're going to be with paul and
terry kiyosaki connolly a bunch of guys
are coming in but we will do a podcast
to cover a bunch of these stories that
we haven't yet
tomorrow morning we're going to do a
podcast just to cover some of these so
we don't normally do it i was out of
town i was out of the country last week
but we're going to do it this week so we
get our two podcasts in having said that
brother thank you so much for coming out
this was a blast my pleasure brother
guys we'll be with you tomorrow take
care bye bye bye
you